[Music]
summer 2019 is almost upon us and with
it comes a slew of exciting anime shows
for everyone to enjoy this year's been a
strong gear when it comes to smash here
anime will 2019 summer match up to the
previous seasons runs we can only wait
and see we start off the list with BEM
at number 10 beams a unique case as it's
a show that's the second remake of a
1960s anime with this one being for the
franchise's 50th anniversary I guess
this is the year of 1960s anime remakes
er I mean we had d'Oro just now as well
the old supernatural action series tells
the story of a trio of yokai who find
themselves living alongside humans
despite being shunned by the humans they
aim to protect the trio continue to
fight in hopes of one day becoming
humans themselves overall it sounds like
a run-of-the-mill supernatural action
series with some superhero esque
elements compared to its previous
versions I'd say this one definitely
looks a lot better than expected from
what we see of the backgrounds to the
character designs only time will tell if
fans would be just as receptive to this
as they were to the remake of d'Oro
[Music]
at number 9 we have Astra lost in space
Kenta Shinohara otherwise known for his
best-selling title sket dance tries his
hand at sci-fi with Astra lost in space
this story set in a distant future where
space travels integrated with everyday
life for nine children on their way to a
planetary camp one fated trip is
anything but ordinary as they encounter
a light sphere that transports them to
an unknown planet the catch they have to
travel five thousand and twelve
light-years to get back home despite the
sci-fi tank being associated with mecha
space drama and a lot of battles Astra
lost in space is a sci-fi series that
doesn't have a lot of combat but what it
lacks in battles that most shown in jump
titles take pride in it makes up for
with a healthy dose of mystery and space
adventures let's come together to see
what adventures await the nine children
on their journey home
[Music]
viii on this list is seven seeds this
anime takes place in the immediate
future where a giant meteorites collided
with earth and wiped out all living
organisms including mankind the
government had foreseen this so they
took measures to counter the worst case
scenario in particular was the project
seven seeds in which five sets of seven
young men and women were carefully
selected and placed into teams each
participant was then put under cryogenic
sleep in the hopes of preserving the
continued existence of mankind that be
released once conditions on earth had
become safe enough for them to live in
now the story begins in an unknown
number of years in the future when one
of the team awakens and learns that
their entire world an old life has been
destroyed an evolution has begun anew if
you're looking for a survival adventure
series with romance and psychological
aspects you should definitely check this
one out when it hits Netflix by the end
of this month
dan Mackey's much awaited second seasons
finally here and it takes the seventh
spot on the list for the little ones who
prayed to the gods for a continuation of
bells journey with the Hestia Familia
wait no more it only took four years a
multitude of spin-offs ova z' and a
movie but fear not for bel Crennel and
the rest of the danmachi cast are here
once more and they're ready to take on
whatever comes their way
this time group warfare takes center
stage in the war games proxy wars that
pit familias against each other with the
winner taking all at the end of this arc
the decisive collision with the soma
familia awaits bill and the Hestia
familia will stop at nothing for victory
but so do their opponents when our
heroes overcome the biggest challenge
yet be sure to stay tuned as danmachi
returns this July
[Applause]
Chinese kick Kings avatar storms in at
number six with its anticipated second
season not too long ago Kings avatar
took the anime world by storm among the
numerous a series that deal with video
games rarely do you see something
focused on eSports with a narrative that
today's youth can really relate to Kings
avatar captivated numerous anime fans
and aspiring pro gamers it's truly a
fresh change of pace to see amidst all
those stories that involve the
characters being transported into game
worlds this time we should expect a
tournament arc where ye shoot attempts
to lead his new team team happy to
greater heights expect a lot of exciting
action and drama as the team joins the
Challenger league this second season
should not disappoint at number five we
have the much-awaited era ferrata they
sure kept everyone waiting for this one
didn't they after numerous delays due to
production issues it's finally time for
the anime community to witness Hajime
Nagumo's one-way trip to the fantasy
world if there are any indications that
the ISA Kai Train isn't stopping anytime
soon this show is definitely one of them
Harry faretta joins the ranks of
seasonal istic either features a weak
and bullied character who eventually
rises and goes from commonplace to the
world's strongest this time though era
faretta looks to rise above the rest of
it skin with its darker toad an antihero
main character we'll see where white fox
will go with this adaptation of the hit
light novel fans of light novel
adaptations featuring overpowered main
characters and the harems shouldn't pass
this one up
fan-favorite accelerator stars of the
fourth anime on the list a certain
scientific accelerator right after we
thought that was it for a certain
magical index j.c.staff comes at us
again with the spin off soaring one of
the franchise's most popular characters
the level 5 s / accelerator as he
continues his recovery at the hospital
accelerator enjoys a relatively peaceful
life the far cry from where we saw him
in index it all changes when he meets a
mysterious girl who has connections with
the last order the ride just doesn't m4
index fans though this time a spin-off
featuring the court accelerators
something that you might want to check
out do take note though that the
experience is more complete if you've
already watched at least the first
season of index so what are you waiting
for start your own adventure into
Academy City and the index series now
[Music]
just when you think you've seen it all
here comes fire force at number three
fire force brings us to a world where a
phenomenon known as spontaneous human
combustion turns humans into infernals
charcoal Mike beings that spread death
and destruction standing against the
rampage of those monsters is the special
fire force a group of trained
individuals that have the ability to
harness the flames within themselves
however there's more than meets the eye
to these burning monstrosity Zsasz
Shinra soon begins to discover the truth
behind the infernals and the mysterious
fire that killed his family I've got to
say soul eaters writer at sushi okobu
showcases his creativity with the many
unique powers featured in the series
with such an engaging manga one can't
help but be excited for the anime series
featuring literal fire fighters the best
part is that the show seems to be in
good hands
if the trailers are any indication to go
by for those craving more Soul Eater
black clover and similar fare this might
be the show for you
[Music]
shounen jump stock tur stone take second
place on the list a bright light appears
in the sky one day it engulfs the world
turning everyone to stone and
effectively putting an end to
civilization as we know it high schooler
Taiji Oki is among the people consumed
and turning to stone but through sheer
willpower he manages to keep himself
alive thousands of years later awakening
to a world of statues Taiji soon finds
out that his science enthusiast friend
ascend KU ishigami also managed to
escape petrification now a new goal
presents itself in front of the two
friends with their complementary talents
they'll begin to rebuild civilization
from zero we've seen the fallout of the
world ending so many times in anime
already but the medium just keeps
throwing surprise after surprise at us
coming from someone who hasn't read the
manga dr. stone really does look quite
interesting survival in a primitive
world stories not something that you see
every day and I'm extremely interested
in seeing how this narrative actually
plays out dr. stone rightfully takes his
place among the most anticipated series
in this upcoming season
[Music]
and at the top of this list we have
Vinland saga the adaptation of makoto
yukimura's manga proudly takes the crown
of the number one most anticipated anime
of summer 2019 Vinland saga revolves
around the story of tor fin Torsen an
Icelandic warrior driven by the fire of
vengeance against his father's killer
looking to exact revenge Torin joins the
Viking group of oskol at his father's
very killer with the promise of a future
duel against the person he swore
vengeance to besides its brutal battles
of inland saga also takes some cues from
history and is actually quite
educational could this be the start of a
resurgence for historical fiction only
time will tell what we know is that
which Studios will have their hands full
where the Vinland saga could replicate
the magic of attack on titan for it
remains to be seen but as far as we're
concerned the hype is off the charts
especially for anime fans in the West
[Music]
all-in-all summer 2019 looks to be
packed with shows for all kinds of
tastes I'm pretty sure that whatever
genre you enjoy you could find something
to look forward to any other shows that
you're excited for if so let us know
we'd love to hear from you so comment
below and like the video if you did and
subscribe for more anime related content
we also finally made it to 500k
subscribers yes thanks to everyone who
subscribed especially those who kept
supporting the channel even after the
changing content thank you so much your
support definitely definitely means a
lot I'll see you next time on vide tube
[Music]